spiritual law you know
the more you
give the more you get i'm not looking to
get more but it's just how the universe
works you know so i believe in that so i
give a lot and i get a lot
what does it mean to give a voice to the
voiceless
well perfect example is our film cicada
uh it's based off a true story um you
know matt shared
an intimate part of his life and the
abuse that he went through and it was
very hard for him to share that and i
remember when we were doing test
screenings of our film
that
we'd have people that we don't know come
to the screenings to give feedback
because we don't want people to say what
we want to hear we want
um
constructive criticism
and this one guy came at the end
came up to matt specifically and said
this was me you know um i've never had
you know the
i've been i've never been able to tell
anyone and what i've went through and
you know um
thank you so much for making this you
know like you've given a voice you know
and that was the first time we had heard
it and we've traveled all over europe
recently with the film and all of the
country with the film it's played at
various festivals and it was in theaters
and there were so many people so many
men that have come up and shared with
the team matt myself kieran um that
we've given them a voice you know
so do a lot of them say they were family
members that did this or
a friend of the family
um
i think it's a combination of both you
know like
they
didn't all go into like great detail
about it you know but um uh they just
wanted to acknowledge that they had gone
through it they understand it
and um
how uh our project was therapeutic
um
so yeah that was more or less how
and so and cicada is also about a
relationship too it's not all about
abuse it's about
two men that find love yeah it's about
an interracial relationship
between these two guys that meet you
know over a summer
um
and it deals with you know
bisexuality which is not touched upon in
film a lot
um in the interracial relationship the
dynamics of that
um it also deals with trauma you know
because there's a lot of trauma around
both characters
and it's at the spirit awards correct
yes it's nominated for best first
screenplay very cool
did you think that that it would have a
chance or did people say oh this this is
not going to sell this is not going to
be something people will be interested
in it might scare people in terms of
anything whether it's the bisexuality
the abuse um in terms of what's selling
the movement yeah would it would it
would it be too much of a hard sell or
would people open welcome it with open
arms because finally people were telling
stories that
it seemed like had been pushed to the
side um
you know along the way i feel like we
made so many errors on that project we
didn't know what to expect i knew it was
a good script
and it changed because
of certain things that had happened
to um seldon in real life which molded
into the script so
what we went
in with initially wasn't what we thought
would end with
um
and uh i think that we did get we
ultimately did when the kenneth reigning
grant you know we got funding from sf
film and kendall freeman grant um and
one of the reasons i think that they got
behind us was our pov you know our point
of view um
and that we were telling a very you know
challenging story um and we needed the
support
um and after we you know won it um they
basically got uh tfi tribeca film
institute involved and you know we were
part of a special uh segment at the
tribeca film festival in 2019
um
and at that point we we didn't know
where we're gonna land but we had
meetings with everybody under the sun
from 824 to you name it that were
interested in one so we knew we had
something special
and that's where we met our sales rep
you know jeffrey winter at film
collaborative who ultimately really
helped
the entire process
you know because he understands the
queer space very well he's been very
successful in the queer space and at the
time when we shot the film my producing
partner jeremy was 21.
um he had just graduated nyu
everyone was in their 20s
i was 34 so i was the grandfather of the
whole group you know
we're very young team and we made a lot
of errors and mistakes and
jeffrey gave us guidance
um
he gave us
confidence in terms of the project he
was like a
godfather to matt
um
and uh he made a lot of introductions
and really supported the film and you
know um and he gave us the pros and cons
in terms of all the distributors that
we're speaking with um
and that really helped the project so we
knew we were gonna land somewhere we
didn't know where we were going to land
and uh the great thing is that we had
options of who we wanted to go with in
the u.s and many of the other countries
that we ended up getting a deal in
um
so
yeah it kind of shaped throughout the
process
and were there certain other countries
that were very open to the film and then
others that refused to have it
uh well we haven't sold all the
territories yet you know so i think that
there's maybe still opportunities to do
that um i don't think it'll sell in
russia you know because they're
anti-queer
um so anyway that's anti-queer probably
is not gonna work and it was interesting
being in poland because um their
government
the country's fastest their government
is anti-queer
if you want to call it a blue dot you
know warsaw and poznan are two places
that are
and um
it was um
you know quite a feat to be able to get
the film there and um and there were
some you know concerns about going there
you know the team was nervous about
going there and like what if something
can happen and you know uh but our pulse
distributor took really good care of us
and um
you know we were with someone the entire
time and they picked us up and kind of
had security detail you know with that
and when i spoke to the people of poznan
you know uh poznan is the biggest queer
city in poland um they were uh just
thrilled to have us and i asked how is
it to live out there what is it like and
you know they consider themselves
freedom fighters you know and standing
up for their rights and this is the way
it is you know they're not gonna back
down
um warsaw is a much bigger city
um
uh i wanna say that uh
they're just a lot more open you know
there uh with that in consideration uh
but we're well received in both cities
and
i want to say with all the other cities
that we've played in so far that's been
the case they were just happy that we're
able to come and engage through intros
and do detailed q and a's you know um
with the audience
um
and the film is coming out in france i
think this month or next month we're not
gonna make that leg uh the friends
didn't necessarily play uh nice with all
the other distributors because when we
went out there it was a coordination
between um our uk distributor um our
polish distributor and german
distributor so france said we're gonna
release when we want to when we feel
like it um you know we don't need to
coordinate with them you know so uh so
we'll be coming out and i'm sure it's
gonna be a huge hit you know in france
and throughout france
so no other countries aside from those
just just it sounds um i believe
switzerland as well because when we sold
germany um you know certain parts of
switzerland are german speaking
i believe and there were talks about
portugal
um but
that's those are all the locations for
for right now
why is it your mission to make these
stories
uh my mission to tell these stories is
very important because uh now i'm gonna
get spiritual with you i consider myself
a light worker and what a light worker
is
is
[Music]
someone in whatever
industry or business
uses their skills or their talents to
make the world a better place and be
kind and
and and help mankind um and i believe
when god gives you or the creator gives
you certain tools
it's your responsibility to share that
with the world so
um i enjoy helping people and there was
a class
that um the new york times had talked
about at harvard that everyone was
looking to get into
and um
and it was
a class on happiness the class had sold
out this was like a couple years ago
um and ultimately when they broke down
the class it was that people are happy
when they help other people that's the
really what it is so i enjoy helping
other people i help
um all walks of life doesn't matter
religion creed whatever and um i know
that if it was me or if it was my family
member and i needed the help you know
because there's times where i do need
help and it's not always necessarily you
know um what i'm giving i'm asking for
back but um this times that i may
struggle with something you know as a
diabetic or
um or you know there was this one time
where i legit lost my wallet in
manhattan and i had no way to get around
or get into anything and um
you know like this person at chase was
very kind to let me take some of my
money out so i can get home but you know
you know i've had times where i've lost
unfortunately it happened a few times
where i've lost my wallet and um and
it's not that i don't have money it's
just i didn't have money on me to be
able to get to where i need to go do
what i need to do and everyone needs
help with something um
so i believe
um that um it's my responsibility to
share that with the world whether it's
speaking engagements you know doing hbcu
tour you know producing these films
around these issues doing social impact
trying to find someone that was falsely
incarcerated and trying to help
rehabilitate them because i'm aware you
know the fact that i'm aware if i did
wasn't aware it's different if i'm aware
and i can do something why not it's not
hurting me you know it's only helping
others and it's helping me and
spiritual law you know
the more you
give the more you get i'm not looking to
get more but it's just how the universe
works you know so i believe in that so i
give a lot and i get a lot
when did you realize you were a light
worker
i want to say it was around that same
time in 2016 when i was in istanbul i
started meeting a lot more light workers
and energy healers and um and learning
more about this world um i had this
woman that was very dear to me um
uh named arlie you know and uh she was a
big
inspiration you know i learned a lot you
know through her and met um a lot of her
friends and colleagues that were um
that
shaped my character and point of view on
these things
uh so i want to say that the tipping
point was probably around 2016.
have you ever
tried to help someone that didn't want
help
all the time you know but one of the
things that i've learned is that i have
to respect that because
um
i can't because if i force it on them
you know it's going to backfire you know
and i may take their karma you know at
the same time so they have to ask for it
you know they have to ask for the help
and want the help because they're not
going to value it at the same time so
um in the beginning or not in the
beginning before you know i was
really into my i found my flow
you know i'd overstep i'd offer advice
when people ask me advice i help people
when they didn't ask for help and and it
would backfire on me because maybe i'd
get frustrated and you know like
wait we didn't ask you to do this you
didn't have to do i didn't want you to
do this you know so there's no
appreciation
so um and i just learned it wasn't on me
like it wasn't my place to tell someone
what they should do if they come to me
and ask it's different thing if they ask
for help but um it was a hard lesson to
learn and even now you know with like
family and friends people that i really
care and love
you know sometimes i want to do stuff
for them but it's not my place and i
have to
you know respect their boundary and
respect that spiritual law that boundary
you